good afternoon
my conviction that this country needs to
go for growth is rooted in my personal
experience
I know what it's like to grow up
somewhere that isn't feeling the
benefits of growth
I saw what that meant
and I'm not prepared to accept that for
our country
I want a country where people can get
good jobs new businesses can set up and
families can afford an even better life
that's why from day one I've been
ambitious for growth
since the 2008 financial crisis the
potential of this great country has been
held back by persistently weak growth
I want to deliver a low tax high-wage
high growth economy
is what I was elected by my party to do
that mission remains
people across this country rightly want
stability
that's why we acted to support
businesses and households with their
energy costs this winter
it's also the case that global economic
conditions are worsening due to the
continuation of Putin's appalling war in
Ukraine
and on top of this debt was amassed
helping people through the covered
pandemic
but it is clear that parts of our mini
budget went further and faster the
markets were expecting
so the way we are delivering our mission
right now has to change
we need to act now to reassure the
markets of our fiscal discipline
I have therefore decided to keep the
increase in corporation tax that was
planned by the previous government
this will raise 18 billion pounds per
year
it will act as a down payment on our
full medium-term fiscal plan which will
be accompanied by a forecast from the
Independent obr
we will do whatever is necessary to
ensure debt is falling as a share of the
economy in the medium term
we will control the size of the state to
ensure that taxpayers money is always
well spent
our public sector will become more
efficient to deliver world-class
services for the British people
and spending will grow less rapidly than
previously planned
I met the former Chancellor earlier
today
I was incredibly sorry to lose him
he is a great friend
and he shares my vision to set this
country on the path to growth
today
I have asked Jeremy Hunt to become the
new Chancellor
he's one of the most experienced and
widely respected government ministers
and parliamentarians
and he shares my convictions and
Ambitions for our country
he will deliver the medium-term fiscal
plan at the end of this month
he will see through the support we are
providing to help families and
businesses including our energy price
guarantee that's protecting people from
higher energy bills this winter
and he will drive our mission to go for
growth including taking forward the
supply side reforms that our country
needs
we owe it to the next Generation to
improve our economic performance
to deliver higher wages new jobs and
better public services and to ease the
burden of debt
I have acted decisively today because my
priority is ensuring our country's
economic stability
as prime minister I will always act in
the National interest
this is always my first consideration
I want to be honest this is difficult
but we will get through this storm and
we will deliver the strong and sustained
growth that can transform the prosperity
of our country for generations to come
I'll now take questions
can I start with Ben Reilly Smith
Telegraph
thank you prime minister clearly a
difficult day can you explain to the
public why you think you should remain
as prime minister given you junk to keep
tax cuts that led you to be elected and
got rid of your Chancellor
I'm absolutely determined to see through
what I've promised to deliver a higher
growth more prosperous United Kingdom to
see us through the storm we Face we've
already delivered the energy price
guarantee making sure people aren't
facing huge bills this winter
but it was right in the face of the
issues that we had
that I acted decisively to ensure that
we have economic stability because that
is vitally important to people and
businesses right across our country
uh
Harry Cole
thank you foreign
you stood on a platform to win the
leadership of the conservative party on
a platform to cut corporation tax you
and the chancellor the ex-chancellor
designed this budget together in
lockstep we're told at times in secret
the two of you he has to go because of
the Fallout from it how come you get to
stay
well my priority is making sure we
deliver the economic stability that our
country needs that's why I had to take
the difficult decisions I've taken today
the mission Remains the Same we do need
to raise our country's economic growth
levels we do need to deliver for people
across the country we're committed to
delivering on the energy price guarantee
which people are already seeing in their
bills but ultimately we also need to
make sure that we have economic
stability and I have to act in the
National interest as prime minister
um
Chris Mason BBC
excuse the bluntness Prime Minister but
given everything that has happened what
credibility do you have to continue
governing
what I've done today
is made sure that we have economic
stability in this country
Jeremy Hunters Chancellor is somebody
who shares my desire for a high growth
low tax economy but we recognize because
of current market issues we have to
deliver the mission in a different way
and that's what we are absolutely
committed to do achieving that stability
and what is a very difficult time
globally
uh
uh Robert peston
prime minister the former Tory
Chancellor Philip Hammond has just said
that you have totally trashed the Tory
parties election winning reputation for
economic competence will you apologize
to your party
well I am determined to deliver on what
I set out when I campaigned to be party
leader we need to have a high growth
economy but we have to recognize that we
are facing very difficult issues as a
country and it was right in the National
interest that I made the decisions I've
made today to restore that economic
stability so we can deliver first of all
helping people through this winter and
next winter with our energy bills but
also making sure that our country is on
the long-term footing for sustainable
economic growth thank you very much
everybody
are you prime minister